So that's a description of mean
shift as applied to segmentation.
It's a, it's a, I will tell you
it's a very strong technique.
The cool thing is it automatically
finds these basins of attraction.
So, you don't have to tell
it how many modes there are.
You just tell it, in fact there's
one parameter choice essentially,
which is that window size,
how big that Gaussian is.
There's also, when you talk about that,
because you're operating in a feature
space, you actually have
a distance function, right?
because when my Gaussian is over
some distance, so if I want to scale
color more than texture, oh, texture,
we haven't talked about that yet.
All right, we'll do that next.
Or color more than luminance you
make that decision ahead of time.
So, there's this parameter
choice of window size, but
there's also a, a general
distance metric function choice.
But you have that in every sort
of clustering that you do.
It doesn't make any assumptions
about the shape of the,
the segment in the image, or the cluster
in the image, it just does this in the,
the probability of
the distribution of the pixels.
And it's a very generic technique for
finding multiple modes,
and people use mean shift for
a variety of things like tracking,
when we actually talked
about doing that previously.
You know, as in anything else
there are some down sides.
It does depend on this window size, and
sometimes figuring out that
window size is a bit of an art,
with respect to the nature of the set
of the images that you're looking at.
And, the other problem is, because you
are sort of moving in feature space, oh,
and, and, you want to make sure that
you get a reasonable number of points
within your, your region of interest
in order to shift the mean.
Well, suppose you've got
a big feature space.
All right, and what I mean by that
is you've got fifty dimensions.
Well, almost by definition,
your future space will be sparse, right?
Because the, sort of,
the number of little, if you,
if you let's suppose you carved
up every dimension into,
like, ten buckets, well,
if there's fifty dimensions right?
That's ten to the 50th buckets.
So by definition,
there's going to be lots and
lots of buckets that have
hardly any points in them.
So mean shift needs you to
have a reasonable number of
points within that region, so it doesn't
work as well in high dimensions.